Tiens, si on refaisait une vidéo de gaming mais cette fois avec des gens... très matures
CL
CHAINE DE VOYANCE https://www.youtube.com/watch?v=DSWQlMv-kLI&t=5s
Tiens, si on refaisait une vidéo de gaming mais cette fois avec des gens... très matures
FAUX!
-On va choisir quelle quête alors? -Vraiment euh... la meilleure!
-On va faire le Dragon des Nimbus
-J'ai joué à ce jeu une seconde dans ma vie donc je suis très très nul
-Bah je te protegerais de toutes façons parce que Donkey Kong je connais toutes ses attaques par coeur
-Tu te la pètes un peu je trouve
-Donc tu t'appelles Senséo? -Senso!
-C'est quelle origine ce prénom? -Italien
-Ah donc tu parles italien? -Non!
-Portugais et Français parce que l'espagnol je connais pas trop.
-Tu nous fais une petite phrase en Portugais ou pas ?
-"La cuenta por favor", "L'addition s'il vous plait"Ce mec parle super bien ESPAGNOL !!!!
-Mais ici on est pour faire une vidéo, pas pour...
-Ah ouais d'accord -...expliquer les langues.
-Ils sont bizarres on dirait qu'ils dansent dans les airs
-On dirait qu'il est bourré
-Toi tu bois souvent de l'alcool ?
-Non
-T'as jamais goûté un petit verre de vin ?
-Si, si
-Ah t'as goûté un verre de vin
-Ouai, je préfère le vin blanc
-Tu préfères le vin blanc ?
-Ouais
"Rire"
-Allez, Sacha on est parti, on prend le petit pont
-Euh, je joue le mec avec une cornemuse et t'es mort !
-T'as perdu, merci Sacha
T'as joué avec nous, ça a pas duré longtemps mais t'étais vraiment un pote
On est toujours avec Noah
Euh.. Non moi j'suis pas Noah, j'suis Maé.
Ah bah t'es son frère
ouais
Vous avez vraiment le même visage
Bah ouais c'est normal on est frères
ehuheeuheuehe
Qu'est ce que tu fais dans la vie Ava?
Alors si vous avez compris envoyer COMPRIS au 81212
T'es en quelle classe Sulice?
CE1
T'apprends quoi à l'école?
Euh les livres.
Tous les livres!?
mfhft
on est avec Chalin
Qu'est ce que tu fais dans la vie?
Je suis collégienne
Tu veux faire ça toute ta vie ou tu veux t'arrêter ?
Si je peux passer à autre chose à un moment
Qu'est-ce que tu veux faire plus tard ?
Technicienne biologiste ouais